[موسيقى]
في الثانيه والعشرين من اذار مارس نفذ
محمد ابو القيعان احد سكان بلده حوره
بالنقب عمليتي تعني ودهسن في بئر السبع
ادت الى مقتل اربعه اسرائيلين واصابه
ثلاثه كما لقي منفذ العمليه حدفه بعدها
بخمسه ايام قتل اسرائيليين واصيب ثلاثه من
الشرطه في اطلاق نار نفذه فلسطينيا قرب
محطه حافلات بمدينه الخضيره داخل الخط
الاخضر ماء مر يوم على العمليه حتى نفذ
الشهيد ضياء حمارشه عمليه النوعيه جديده
حيث جنه هجوما مسلحا قتل فيه اربعه
اسرائيليين في بني براك شرقه الاديب
وتمكنت الشرطه الاسرائيليه من تصفيته بعد
خمس ساعات من المطارده
وفي سبع من ابريل نفذ الشهيد رعد حازم
عمليه في قلب تل ابيب ادت الى مقتل ثلاثه
اسرائيلين واصابه 10 لكنه تعرض للتصفيه
بعد مطارده استمرت تسع ساعات
في الخامس من الشهر التالي قتل ثلاثه
اسرائيلين واصيب ثلاثه في هجوم مسلح نفذه
الشابان اسعد الرفاعي وصبحي ابو شقير داخل
متنزه في مدينه العام شرقه الابيبه وبعد
يوم من المطارده تم اعتقالهما وفي منتصف
شهر سبتمبر سادف الشهيدان احمد وعبد
الرحمن عابد باطلاق نار جنود الاحتلال على
حاجز الجلمه في جنين وقتلا ضابطا
اسرائيليا ثم استشهد في تبادل اطلاق النار
مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه بعد شهر من ذلك
محمد صوف حيث دهس عدد من المستوطنين فقتل
ثلاثه منهم ونفذ عمليه طعن اصاب بها
اسرائيل قبل ان يتمكن الجيش الاسرائيلي من
قتله وقتل مستوطن الاسرائيلي في الثالث
والعشرين من نوفمبر واصيب 22 في تفجير
مزدوج وقع في مدينه القدس
[موسيقى]